let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud and
do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
well hello out there
it is wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern you know what that
means you're joining me here on let's
talk
the tony michaels podcast of course
i am the tony michaels
and today we are gonna talk
about the dumb [ __ ]
that is all around us everywhere it is
[ __ ] everywhere everywhere you look
everywhere you peek under each rock
nook cranny is a bunch of [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] everywhere so that's what's
gonna fill the entire hour today
because we have just loads
of these q anon manga trump humping
spread necks
everywhere they're [ __ ] everywhere
so we're going to talk about that today
of course
to start us off i think i'll go over uh
the
the my pillow not see mike lindell and
some of the garbage that he's been
talking about with this election
it's getting worse and worse and worse
for these fools uh with this august 13th
deadline this goal post that they set in
that they're gonna have to move again
it's getting closer and closer and
they're getting more nervous and more
nervous
and their story changes and they're the
crazy is all over the [ __ ] map
the main part of our show though today
is i want to talk about
trump's coup his cheeto dust
kangaroo coup that he was trying to
commit uh with his
acting attorney general jeffrey rosen uh
the assistant attorney general
jeffrey clark and his little letter that
he wanted to submit to the state of
georgia to try to overturn
that free and fair election and then you
know there's
again there's the deputy uh donahue but
but more importantly there's rosen and
jeffrey rosen and jeffrey clark
the story of the jeffries and what that
possibly means for the former guy
the cheeto dust mobster
and then i also want to talk about
uh which i got to be careful here
because youtube
youtube will ban the [ __ ] out of you
will suspend the [ __ ] out of you if you
say the wrong
things about the wrong things
so we're going to tiptoe around and talk
about cue and honors
and some of their hesitancy
with uh a a a shmaxine
right a schmaxine
and we also have a new uh uh uh
of uh shmorona virus
i'm it's ridiculous that we can't talk
about a goddamn virus on youtube and
tell the [ __ ] truth without them
going ah misinformation
because i'm mocking the misinformation
i'm mocking it i'm mocking the
misinformation is what i'm doing
youtube i'm not spreading it i'm mocking
it because it's
dumb [ __ ] but anyways
there's a new variant there was a report
youtube
youtube there was a report it's news i'm
just
i'm just restating it
that south korea has found a new variant
it's it's related to the delta variant
that is spreading around this country
it's called delta plus so we're going to
talk about the stupid name they give it
gave it sorry the stupid name they
gave the the new variant
i'm going to talk about that and then
we're going to talk about all the
governors out there that are just
these republican governors these
republican constituents these
unvaccinated people
they they are on a freight train that is
about to crash into a goddamn wall here
and i got i got a plenty of tick tocks
about this you know it
you [ __ ] know it i got plenty of tick
tocks that we're gonna play
and try to explain some of this stuff um
to everybody
but let's start let's start with the my
pillow nazi
mike lindell so i mean i tweeted this
there is a video
and someone's trolling the [ __ ]
he's sitting at some
sort of courtyard or i don't know if
this is
some kind of you know hotel where he
meets up with uh
gals on craigslist or something but it
really looks kind of suspicious
but he's set up on a courtyard on a uh
on an outdoor table
and he's got his camera and he he
doesn't have any pants on
he's out in the open he's got a suitcase
he doesn't have any pants on he's
pantsless
the [ __ ] doesn't have pain he
couldn't even put
a pair of pants just put blue jeans on i
know you own some
some [ __ ] grandpa blue jeans
you [ __ ] mustache mussolini what are
you doing sitting out front of everybody
without your goddamn pants on you
[ __ ] weirdo
is this guy still on crack is he still
on crack
is that what this is because it really
does seem like this guy's on crack
because he's all over the [ __ ] map
remember
remember august 13th next friday next
friday
uh the former guy the cheeto dust
mobster is going to
rise from the dead and ascend to the
presidency again somehow i don't know i
guess
uh last just a few days ago last week he
was saying that biden and harris are
going to resign
uh at the same exact time when you know
he comes out with all his information on
august 12th or august i don't
know september 89th who the [ __ ] tell
with these people so the goal post is
coming up here so they got to figure out
a way to move it
so he's trying to figure out a way that
he can [ __ ] move this goal post
because it's going to come up there
ain't going to be [ __ ] that happens
and then and he's going to have to
create a new event
that's going to happen a new end of the
world type [ __ ]
[ __ ] nostradamus over there you think
for a guy
that [ __ ] manufactured pillows he
would take a [ __ ] nap every once in a
while
jesus [ __ ] christ this guy
so in the interview i guess where he was
pantsless i don't know
he's talking about the georgia race and
the senate race
because he's wanting to overthrow all
these elections the arizona audit and
georgia and
you know just on and on and on with this
dominion machine
stuff if just just [ __ ] absolute
trash
so he's talking about georgia and how
the democrats were greedy
that they stole two seats in georgia
what okay he's talking about the runoff
not not that not the actual the the
general election he's talking about the
runoff election
where warnock and ossoff won
now the same people who voted
for ossoff voted during that same time
on the same ballot
as warnock like they voted on the same
[ __ ] ballot there wasn't
two ballots there was one ballot with
both their names on it
so the people who got a ballot or who
wanted to get a ballot and wanted to
vote
they had the opportunity to vote for
both senators at the same god damn time
do you does this guy not know how
[ __ ] elections work
did he not go vote does he not vote
has he never seen a [ __ ] ballot
of course the democrats won both seats
the democrats were gonna win both seats
are the republicans were gonna win both
seats
and trump made sure that trump made sure
that in at the end of december in the
beginning of january
the [ __ ] is this guy talking about we
got greedy
listen the next time us libtards cheat
are all you liptards listening out there
because i got a message for you
the next time we decide to cheat why
don't we go ahead and get
60 senators let's do that that way we
can overturn the filibuster
and and and give a bunch of liberal
libtard stuff to the entire country
you know crazy radical things like
universal healthcare make sure
people have a a decent [ __ ] wage
you know crazy radical stuff get the
actual
[ __ ] out of here what are you talking
about democrats got [ __ ]
greedy if we were greedy we'd have took
90 [ __ ] seats
what are you talking about if we wanted
to cheat and we did cheat we'd [ __ ]
make it count
dumbass
the pantsless pillow guy the pantsless
pillow nazi
oh so let's move on from that dumb [ __ ]
as
er er er as relevant as it may seem
which it's [ __ ] not
and i can't wait to get to january 13th
to hear what this [ __ ] idiot's next
goal post is going to be
it'll be even dumber than the the august
13th
uh goal post here that we're gonna that
we're gonna look at next
next friday and i'm sure he'll have all
kinds of great
great information and all the
information just change all of our minds
all of a sudden i'm sure
i'm sure of it yeah okay
now let's get into the real the real
news that i want to talk about today
because a lot of people
um are talking about
a lot of people are talking about
this jeffrey clark letter down to george
and i think it's very important
i think the jeffrey clarke uh
letter to georgia is super important
here
and i think i think a lot of people are
going to be in trouble over this
this letter i think i think mr jeffrey
clark
might have a subpoena in his future i
believe that jeffrey rosen is definitely
going to have a subpoena in his future
and so
is mr donahue if you don't know jeffrey
rosen
uh is the was the acting attorney
general
so in december you remember bill barr is
like ah
i might retire before trump
gets out of office and everyone's like
what the [ __ ] he's like i want to go on
vacation
for christmas and then after christmas i
don't want to have to worry about this
government stuff
anymore and then
a few weeks later he just all said and
resigned just all of a sudden
he resigned and then all of a sudden
jeffrey rosen
who was the deputy attorney general at
the time becomes the
assistant or it becomes the acting
attorney general
because there's not enough time for
trump to appoint an attorney general and
get them you know
confirmed through the senate by the time
he would be kicked out of office which
he was
by your daddy joe biden that's right yo
daddy
joe biden so
jeffrey rosen becomes the acting
attorney general which he puts in place
uh donahue which is his deputy attorney
general which is basically the number
two
and then there's the assistant attorney
general which is jeffrey clark
and it's confusing because there's so
many scumbags in this scheme
there's always always always always so
many [ __ ] scumbags in these
these trumpism uh schemes and these
crimes that they're committing
so jeffrey clark decides to write a
letter uh to
the the the governor of
georgia and also the secretary of state
of georgia
and says hey hey that whole georgia
election
we want you guys not to do that just say
it was fake and you're not certifying it
and it's
it's all not real it's just not
it's like it never even happened because
you know trump lost
and we don't want him to lose and we
want him to be king
so let's do that now you can read the
actual letter if you want to read the
[ __ ]
it's on it's on the internet but there's
not any real reason to go
read the [ __ ] so
so it is presented to
jeffrey rosen and donahue because trump
loves the idea trump loves the idea of a
soft coup
he loves the idea of a soft coup that
way georgia can say
nope it's all fake it was all fraud
it it was a it didn't happen
joe biden did win and the reason why he
wanted one of these states because even
if georgia didn't fall
even if georgia fell if you do the math
if you do the electoral college math and
he didn't
and joe biden didn't win georgia that
wasn't going to
prevent him from being president of the
united states i wasn't going to put him
in a position where he didn't have
enough electoral votes
because he had arizona he had nevada and
he had pennsylvania
i mean trump lost more than just one
[ __ ] state but what he
wanted now we know what he wanted
what he wanted was for someone
someone to say it was fraud
it's fake they stole it because then he
could get out in front of a microphone
and say see
see see see this person saying this
person's saying that person's saying
this person's investigating
that person's investigating it's all
happening it's all happening
that's all he wanted because we see it
we see it in the notes
with the notes to when he's meeting with
jeffrey rosen the acting attorney
general
he says just say the elections of fraud
just say it's a fraud
you don't have to give evidence just say
it's a fraud in front of a microphone
and then me and the republican
congressman will do the rest
in other words we'll gaslight the rest
of the country we'll really put that
fascist [ __ ] out there
we'll really bury this this country and
nazi propaganda that's what we'll do
that's how we'll steal the election no
one will ever believe that i lost
when you say that i didn't lose i'll
make it happen
this sounds familiar doesn't it doesn't
it sound familiar
remember there was a lady that ran 2016
and they couldn't stop talking about her
[ __ ] emails
still can't stop talking about her
[ __ ] emails they ran the same goddamn
game plan with that and the next time it
happened
the first time the [ __ ] was
impeached when he was terrified of joe
biden
absolutely terrified he was terrified of
joe biden
so much so that he does the same
thing that he tried to do to jeffrey
rosen
the attack acting attorney general the
end of the december the beginning of
january
he tries on the president of ukraine
gets on the phone remember the phone
call oh the perfect phone call it was
perfect it was perfect
that's nice military aid you got there
it would be a shame to something
happened to it
i need you to get in front of a
microphone mr
president of ukraine and i need you to
say you're investigating joe biden
and the reason why is because without
someone saying it
i can't say someone's doing it
i need a little chicken nugget of
misinformation
of lies to create a bigger
lie and to create a bigger lie and to
create a bigger lie
so much so that my supporters won't know
what the truth in reality is
if their heads were halfway up their
asses which is all the way up their
asses
so that was the strategy it's becoming
clear
now what the strategy was for this
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
the strategy was was to get the attorney
general the act
well i believe the attorney general bill
barr told him to go
[ __ ] himself because i think bill bart
said look i'm not ending i'm not gonna
end up in federal prison
what are you [ __ ] nuts not for you
not for you you dumb [ __ ] you
lost by eight million votes you got cl
in modern and modern days here in the
last four or five presidencies you got
clobbered more than anyone else has ever
got clobbered
i'm not standing up for you and i want a
book deal
dummy it's hard to get a book deal when
you're running the federal prison i mean
you get one after federal prison i mean
everyone gets one after but when you're
on your way you don't get one
but bill barr i believe we're gonna find
out said no
no i'm not doing the whole coup thing
you are not a king you are a buffoon
and bill barr told him to go [ __ ]
himself
and that's when bill barr stepped away
and that's when rosen came in and then
rosen wouldn't do it either
and it's clear now we know that rosen
wouldn't do it
and i believe that's this drip drip drip
because i've i've talked to several
people in personal conversations i've
heard this
uh people typing this out on twitter uh
people even commenting and some of the
things that i've
tweeted saying that donald trump is not
gonna pay a price here
he's gonna get away with this he's gonna
fly the coop he's not going to get away
he's going to get away with all of it
you have to understand something this is
a former president united states as much
as we
we don't he really didn't do much as
president he was a
you know a bum but he was actually held
the office of
president of the united states they
can't just run on down to mar-a-lago
kick in the door and arrest the guy
they really got to build a case against
this [ __ ] because not only
not only is this son of a [ __ ] a former
president united states
this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
is the king of chaos and they know
what's going to happen
they know what's going to happen
anything that
when when when the shoes do drop
him and the trump apparatus the trump
machine
you know newsmax oan fox news tucker
carlson
greg kelly any of these [ __ ] trumpian
pieces of garbage out there the q anon
universe
they are going to they are going to pile
chaos onto this country when this
happens
going to pile chaos on this country
but what this drip drip drip is and this
select committee
is going to do with the drip drip drip
and the testimony that happens and the
evidence that is laid before the
american people
about how trump wanted a soft
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
is to show hey little by little yep
this guy's a [ __ ] bag holy [ __ ] we
thought
he was bad he's worse than he actually
than we ever thought he was
and that's what this drip drip trip is
is because they have to
build this case in the public forum
because we've never
we've never put a former president of
the united states
in a prison state federal otherwise
never happened it has not happened yet
and i believe this guy has got one of
the best chances of
you know doing that at this point
but the thing that strikes me the most
about the news with the rosen and some
of the notes and the letter that's come
out
is when trump says he said it to rosen
he said
you just say there's fraud and lead the
rest up to me
and the republican congressman
that seems kind of funny doesn't it it
seems kind of funny to me
it's kind of odd that the that the
republican congressman wanted to be on
the select committee
you watched it when jim jordan was
appointed to select committee
and nancy pelosi the gqp kryptonite
she slam dunks that [ __ ] in the
trash
nope not on this committee [ __ ] not on
my
watch she says not gonna happen
mr jim jordan you are a material witness
and now we're starting to see why jim
jordan is material witness
and he's done several interviews his
[ __ ] [ __ ] bag
he's done several interviews and then
he's been asked the question
did you did you or did you not talk to
the president
on january 6 while the insurrection was
happening
did you or did you not kevin mccarthy's
gonna have the same
questions that are gonna have to be
answered with the subpoena
that's why nancy pelosi didn't let him
be on the [ __ ] select committee
he was on the list of subpoenas and it's
hard
it's hard to ask yourself questions
in a select committee hearing it really
is hard what are you gonna do
mr jordan and then he runs around to the
table answers his own question
runs back asks a question runs back you
cannot have a material witness
to a select committee be part of that
committee can you imagine
if the democrats would appointed hillary
clinton to the benghazi committee
holy [ __ ] imagine if that happened
imagine imagine
the heads that would explode if hillary
clinton somehow would have been
nominated to the benghazi select
committee oh that would have been
[ __ ] fabulous wouldn't it
hmm well maybe i come up with a new
nugget of information here
just imagine if hillary clinton
was nominated as a member
of the benghazi select committee
put that into context that's what jim
jordan was
he's a [ __ ] material witness not only
did he talk to the president that day
they probably were yucking it up on the
phone about how well it was going
look at all those people aoc and pelosi
and mike pence they just ran away
they ran away
it was probably a celebration just like
they were celebrating in the tent
him and don jr mark meadows those [ __ ]
i did a tick tock about this can you
believe that can you can you imagine me
doing a tick tock about
about the republican congressman that he
was going to
uh so chaos on the country once jeffrey
rosen got out in front of a microphone
and declared fraud in the election when
there was none
i did a tick talk about it let me play
the tick tock and then we'll
we'll go on the other side have you ever
noticed that republican congressman
tried to help grandpa poopypants
overthrow the united states constitution
with his cheeto dust kangaroo coup
i'm talking to you mo brooks and jim i
don't report sex crimes jordan
you've skeezed up trees in this [ __ ]
[ __ ] em well
there's a lot more on the list than just
mo brooks and jim jordan but you only
have so much time in it
in a little video so uh you know
and we've already seen this the
department justice says we are not
providing legal assistance
it is not executive privilege you do not
have any kind of privilege
mr gozar you do not have any privilege
mr brooks
it seems as if it seems as if jim jordan
maybe even matt getz
was in communication we know kevin
mccarthy was in communication we know he
was
he has all admitted that he was on the
phone with the president of the united
states
during during the insurrection
and the reports are that the president
said kevin mccarthy doesn't love his
country as much as
the supporters who were storming the
capital trying to overthrow the country
don't you [ __ ] get it they
were trying to overthrow the united
states of america
the constitution the thing that they
carry around in their
pocket for years they've been they've
been [ __ ]
lecturing us on the goddamn constitution
for [ __ ] years
they were trying to overthrow that
document
mark milly even said it had to say it
three times
in public before january 6. and before
january 20 at the inauguration hey
remember
military active military your oath is to
a document it's called the constitution
not a person they were trying to
overthrow the constitution
that's what their goal was
and trump was at the head of the spear
and we know that now
and there's going to be more folks
there's gonna be way more
this is only a tip of the iceberg this
is this this is not
even the seasoning on the entree here
with this rosen jeffrey clark letter
trying to overthrow
i would imagine that trump was he wasn't
doing anything
he was so goddamn desperate to remain in
power and the reason why is to stave off
any kind of federal investigations into
his inaugural committee
or anything else his business dealings
his
taxes here we are with his tax returns
again
they're gonna get them they're gonna get
the tax returns we're gonna find out how
[ __ ] broke he is
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen
just a bunch a dumb [ __ ]
bunch of dumb [ __ ]
and it all seems to come it all comes
from one side in this country they just
it just constant
it's constant it just you can't shut it
off
you can't shut the [ __ ] stupid off
because we have
two viruses running around this country
spreading like wildfire
and it's just the spread nicks the q
anon maga
trump humping evangelical spread knicks
that are spreading both viruses
both of them the coronavirus
in the in the way of the delta variant
and then this stupid virus
it's stupid what the [ __ ] are you people
talking about
and it's been no more clear
then when when you have to [ __ ]
explain
masking vaccines to these people holy
actual [ __ ] we have been doing this
for a year and a half now a year and a
half we've been doing this [ __ ] now to
you know
to everyone's credit rather no matter
what your support was no matter who you
supported
no matter what you did during the
pandemic rather you paid attention to
science or not to everyone's credit
january february march it was hard to
tell what the hell this thing was
it was hard to tell we didn't know we
didn't know we knew
it was deadly we knew it was a virus we
didn't know how much it spread you just
didn't
no but by april and may we
we started to know and definitely by the
end of last summer
we sure as hell knew in this country
what the hell it was how it worked
what what mitigated it and what didn't
it's not [ __ ] rocket science that if
you
don't breathe and sneeze on people it
helps mitigate them getting sick and
your community and your family
and your friends and your coworkers sick
it helps
that helps it kind of works
and here we are in this country
right now a pandemic of the unvaccinated
because that's what's happening that's
what's happening
you look at all the hospitalization
numbers
you look at those numbers there is a
slim number
of people who are vaccinated that are
even hospitalized let alone the death
numbers very few are dying that are
vaccinated
it just is not happening
the people who are getting sick getting
hospitalized and dying
are the unvaccinated now rather they're
unvaccinated because
they believe the [ __ ] that's the
question
story after story after story after
story
we hear of an unvaccinated person being
hospitalized and pleading
pleading from their hospital bed
for their fellow citizens family and
community to get vaccinated that they
were wrong
they were fed a line of [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] that i believed that aunt sally
was posting on facebook
holy [ __ ] all those stupid [ __ ]
youtube videos
that are were [ __ ] lying to me they
were lying to me
holy [ __ ] i can't imagine can't imagine
they were [ __ ] lying to me
and they gotta find someone the
republicans
the gqp that the trump machine
has to find someone to blame it on
because it's getting blamed on him
all of it the whole [ __ ] caboodle
getting blamed on him
because he politicized it
he politicized it did a video about it
yup me did a video about it did a tic
tac
liberals are not making the virus of the
vaccine
science is not making the vaccine
or the virus doctors are not making
the vaccine or the virus
school boards school boards are not
making the vaccine or the virus the
health departments and counties and
cities
are not making the vaccine and the virus
political
they're not they're not
it is you [ __ ] boneheaded spread
necks out there
that are making this political
don't you see it well let me show it to
you
let me show it to you politics will kill
you let's talk
so the q anon maga trump humping
covidient republicans in this country
think that science is making the virus
in the vaccine political
what the [ __ ] the ones running around
all over the country saying i'm not
getting the vaccine because i'm a
republican
not taking it cause i don't know what's
in it even though the fda gives a list
of [ __ ] that's in it
[ __ ] the fda for keeping us safe [ __ ]
them ask don't work then the vaccine
must not work and if the vaccine doesn't
work then mass nuts might not work
either
i'll just take my chances with death
don't you wish these dumb [ __ ] would
just say the argument that they actually
have
look it's my right to get sick and died
to own the libtards you know freedom and
[ __ ]
here's where you're gonna want to turn
the volume up you dumb [ __ ]
if it really was political if it really
was don't you think us libtards would
let natural selection kick in and kill
off a few hundred thousand trump voters
go get vaccinated you nasty infected
[ __ ]
[ __ ] them well
it's tough but it's not political
because if it was political we would
take advantage of it wouldn't we
i mean jesus christ we took advantage of
the dominion machines we took advantage
of the election
and we totally we totally rigged that up
to make sure that joe biden was the fake
president in hollywood
or some dumb [ __ ] i don't know
pluck your head out of your [ __ ]
asses
it's not political go get vaccinated
you know it would be one thing it would
be one thing if all of us
didn't get vaccinated and we were
telling the
uh all the trump voters to go get we
didn't we're not getting vaccinated
but you should you should get no we got
vaccinated
we got it and we know the truth because
we are
we are we're vaccinated i'm vaccinated
fully fully vaccinated
two shots two shots of moderna i'm fully
vaccinated
i know the truth i know the truth it's
not
[ __ ] with me you know what's not
[ __ ] with me the delta variant
that's what's not [ __ ] with me
because i'm vaccinated
go get your [ __ ] nasty ass vaccinated
if you're not already
go go it's getting ridiculous
and i made the analogy this morning i
made the analogy
this morning on twitter and some people
didn't like it but
with my mantra [ __ ] them you really
think a guy like me gives a [ __ ]
i made the analogy this morning of 9 11
being like this [ __ ] vac the vaccine
and the delta variant that we're going
through
here's my thought process let me show
you the tweet here
so it says when are we going to realize
that this is a war on the virus
we're at war with this virus we're at
war we're dying
and there's another variant coming
there's another threat
getting vaccinated is the weapon to win
the war against this threat and the next
threat
think of the delta plus variant as a
terrorist
and we need to stop delta plus in its
tracks
and i posted i posted
a picture of the twin towers before they
fell
why they were on fire and i posted a
picture of george w
bush standing on the pile rubble for the
twin towers do you remember
that time can you can you conjure up
can you conjure up enough [ __ ]
honesty
enough [ __ ] reality to tether
yourself to
to remember how you felt in that moment
not about war not about going to war
but about your fellow citizens think
about it
just just stop sit there and think
about how did i feel
when george w bush someone who i don't
vehemently disagree with
stood on the pile of rubble and said
we're coming to get you
whoever did this we're coming to get you
because
we're america and we don't we
don't care if we disagree there's one
thing you're not gonna do
and you're not gonna [ __ ] with us that
is the feeling
that is the feeling that you should have
for this vaccine
for your fellow americans for your
community members for your family
for your friends think back
use your old thinking machine and think
back on that
moment if you were there if you were
alive
because as much as it seems like modern
history by god
it's almost 20 years ago
so if you're out there and you were
there and you watched it
you watched them fall you watch them
stand on that pile rubble
and i'm not talking about war i'm not
talking about who we're gonna go to war
with
i'm talking about how you felt about
your your fellow
citizens your so-called patriotism
you [ __ ] trump humping fools
conjure up enough [ __ ] honesty in
yourself tether yourself to enough
[ __ ] reality
to realize the stakes here it ain't got
nothing to do with your body and your
choice
it has to do with all of us all of us
and some of these republicans some of
them are understanding that
like today the the governor of arkansas
asha hutchinson comes out to a press
conference
and he regrets he regrets signing
the the ban on mass mandates
he regrets signing you regret signing it
into law now
well yeah now that it's killing your
[ __ ] constituents
you're murdering them and i don't know
if it's murder if they're letting them
be murdered
i don't know anymore i don't know
i mean it's there it's my rat
to get the virus and die to own the
libtards because that's really what it
seems like at this point
it's really what it seems like
i mean asha hudson really regrets
the anti uh mass mandate bill
uh today greg abbott's little bill in
texas where he's gonna pull over
immigrants and [ __ ] with brown people
because of the virus and this is what
they're doing with the immigration
the immigrant the immigrants that they
keep illegally
they keep blaming it on brown people
that that's the oh that's the old
gqp's solution everything
just blame those brown people if all
else fails blame people of color
that's what they do you remember when
trump came down the escalator and
that was the start of the whole thing
rapist coming across the border you
remember now
now they're infected coming across the
border because it's easy it's easy to
really conjure up someone to blame
because they tried to blame china
that didn't work so well they tried to
brain
joe biden that didn't work for more than
a millisecond
they really really really want to pin
this on dr
fauci but that's not working at all that
really
is getting no [ __ ] traction at all to
blaming on
dr fauci and they had bill gates there
for a little bit too
now they're back to the old sideshow
trick
blame it on brown people [ __ ] you newt
gingrich
st fox business talking about how
they're coming over and this is what
radical democrats want is
all these infected brown people come
here to
get rid of white i don't want the [ __ ]
he's talking about
someone get that [ __ ] of some a
goddamn nursing home bed or something
jesus christ
today we have death santas
you [ __ ] desantis who is trying
to prevent
school boards and local governments to
do what they
want to do their body their choice
that's where we're going to go with it
he's talking about
immigrants coming across the border in
florida or some [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is he talking about the
border of where
georgia and alabama the ocean
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
immigrants coming across the border
and then he'll consider helping with the
virus or some dumb [ __ ]
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] your citizens
are dying you dumb [ __ ]
they're dying they're dying and it
doesn't give a [ __ ] if you're white
black brown it doesn't care if you're
young old male
female it does not give a [ __ ]
the only thing that the virus really
gives the [ __ ] about it seems like
is if you're vaccinated or not
or if you got a mask over your face
so school boards down in florida want to
do the local government thing
do you remember when republicans and
the gop used to give us these lectures
about big government and federal
governments bad
only government is local government let
the local governments handle it
they'll handle everything we don't need
no federal
government they didn't actually believe
that [ __ ] they never
they don't have any real principles
never have never will
because now that you have local
governments not the big
federal government but local governments
like counties city health departments
like school boards
trying to make decisions that are good
for their staff and their students and
their communities
ah nope nope big state governments gotta
come in
the big bad state government where the
[ __ ] is your principles at oh that's
right you had none
you have none fascism
fascism are you guys catching on to this
you hear it
the big bad local school board is the
enemy here
you know they now are
now they are now i bet i bet
ron desantis would be okay
would be perfectly okay if the school
board wanted to
i don't know ban something like the
words critical race theory
oh he'd be he'd be all in support of
local school board governments oh he'd
be
he'd be ecstatic that'd be fantastic
but when they want to do something that
helps the school helps the community
so they're not getting sick nope
can't do that can't do that big bad
local government
jesus [ __ ] christ you can't make this
[ __ ] up will you [ __ ] believe
something and [ __ ] believe it i
actually i did a video
and i had an ending on the video that
really describes
all these q anon maga trump pumping
evangelical spread neck
anti-mask anti-vaxxer gqp
jesus christ we got a long list of [ __ ]
that that we gotta include to describe
these [ __ ] now
it's getting ridiculous it's getting
ridiculous because you know what you
know when they were all separated
when you separate all of them out all
the stupid when you separate all the
stupid out
you know it spreads it around spreads it
around a bit but now they all
gathered up in one [ __ ] spot
it's like when you're trying to make a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
you know what i'm talking about you're
trying to spread the peanut butter on
the bread
you know it works really well when you
can spread it edge to edge
but when it's really clumpy and hard and
it gets caught in the middle it makes
for a really shitty sandwich
that's what this is a [ __ ] sandwich
and here's a little video describing
them you [ __ ] really are dumber than a
bag of goddamn hammers
[ __ ] them maybe we should just play that
every single time we hear one of these
dumb [ __ ] whether it's mike lindell
trump uh desantis
abbott hutchinson down in arkansas
mike parson here in missouri which i'm
not even going to get to that
[ __ ] today because we're going to run
out of time because i got so much dumb
[ __ ] to talk about it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous i'm gonna have to change
to doing 12 hours a [ __ ] week
just to explain all the dumb [ __ ]
that's going on with you dumb
[ __ ]
dumber than a bag of goddamn hammers
they are
so there is progress though being made
on the delta variant and i believe
that what is going to save this country
is reasonable people out there
reasonable people
no matter who you voted for what your
politics are reasonable people
uh are going to get vaccinated they're
going to abide by
uh masks either mandated or recommended
the reasonable people are going to do
that and i believe that
private companies are going to step in
here and really
make sure that the morons can't
participate
without doing the things that they're
required to do like they did last year
let me explain this so last year in 2020
when the virus was running across the
country
and we have uh we we had a lot of you
know the states were opening back up but
we had a lot of dumb bucks
that thought that it was over you know
in may june
july and the the retail company said
nope
nope nope you cannot come in our stores
without a mask
you gotta wear a mask because that was
really the best mitigation tactic at the
time
in an indoor setting was putting a mask
on and trying to social distance
like that was the best mitigation tactic
that we had last summer
that was it we didn't have the vaccine
yet
that was the mitigation tactic that we
had so the private industry out there
said well that is the best mitigation
tactic
to keep our employees and our customers
from getting sick
so we're going to implore those
strategies those
mitigation strategies inside of our
stores as policy
and it worked to an extent still killed
a lot of people
a lot of americans died last year
needlessly
but private industry did step in and
probably saved
hundreds of thousands of people um
now i don't know what the exact number
may be but
uh it's it's kind of crazy now this net
this variant that's going around right
now as many people as being hospitalized
and many people aren't vaccinated that
are getting sick
they're probably gonna it's probably
gonna kill another 150
000 between now and the end of the year
that's what they're estimating
so these companies
tyson food walmart most the tech
companies facebook
google um even fox news
oh the irony even fox news is doing a
vaccine
vaccine requirement now it's not exactly
a mandate because the requirement what
it's saying is you're required to get a
vaccine
or this which is some kind of
protocol some kind of protocol you know
what i mean
like a protocol where you have to test
and test make sure you're not wear a
mask
those sort of things you know mitigate
your risk if you're not vaccinated
either get vaccinated
which is a requirement and if you can't
you have to use these mitigation tactics
to keep everyone else safe
up and i've been saying this privately
for weeks that
i thought walmart should have done this
two months ago
walmart should have stepped in and done
this two months ago they did the other
day
tyson food was the other big one to drop
there's a lot of tech companies that did
it
but i think walmart and i know it sounds
crazy but i think walmart doing it
uh they could lead the way they could
really lead the way they've got enough
[ __ ] money and enough power
to fight [ __ ] like this in court if
someone wants to challenge them
to slam dunk this [ __ ] because everyone
knows that this is constitutional
to require your employees to get a
vaccine it happens all the time now
it's it's been happening this is not a
thing
that is not that is unconstitutional it
is constitutional 100 percent
and i i hope they challenge it i hope
they do
i hope they challenge it because there's
already predicate to
to know that it is 100 in the private
employer's right to say you are required
to get this vaccine
to work here they already do that
they do it already dummies
so i think tyson food and walmart doing
this is a big step
and the reason why is because where
tyson food and walmart is generally
located
and where they're generally at in these
areas where the rise in this delta
variant is happening
the more they stick their necks out the
more someone else will stick their necks
out
that's the whole purpose but the
mitigation tactics are super important
super important and we actually have the
we did this debate on social media a
couple days ago
about mitigation tactics and how it is
very important to have a protocol if
you're gonna have big events
and these people are gonna find out why
they're not invited to big events
when they don't have a protocol in place
meaning they're not vaccinated
when you can't go inside of a certain
place or you can't go get a certain
ticket or you can't get on an airplane
or train
because you're not vaccinated there's a
certain protocol it happened when
uh there was an announcement that
president obama which president obama
turned 60 today it's his birthday happy
birthday president obama he's 60 today
but the announcement was the news was
that he was going to have an outdoor
birthday party at martha's vineyard and
i think there was a couple hundred
people that were supposed to be invited
and the right lost their minds how could
you do this
oh you're gonna spread that that wait i
mean we had magor always all summer
last year this year unmasked it killed
herman cain
really you're i i can't it's it though
you can't even
make this [ __ ] up that they don't
understand this
the protocols were put in place
apparently by this birthday party it's a
private birthday party
for obama it's outdoors and they have a
protocol in place
a protocol you're going to hear that a
lot dumb [ __ ]
open your get the [ __ ] wax out of
your ears
maybe you need the wax and backs
get the [ __ ] wax out of here so you
can hear it protocol
protocol protocol protocol the main
protocol is going to be go get your ass
with a vaccine in your arm that's going
to be the main protocol that's going to
be the first step
so learn the word look it up google that
[ __ ] go to the google machine
and google that [ __ ] but i did a
i did a little video of course on the uh
obama's birthday party because i
surmised that there might have been a
reason
why they weren't they weren't
as excited about an obama birthday party
as they were
a maga rally that was a super spread
neck event
you ever noticed that the kunan maga
trump humpers
are only concerned about spreading the
delta variant
to the unvaccinated when the former
black dude throws an outdoor birthday
party
you covered kool-aid drinking spread
neck
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] them
yeah well i mean that's
that's it and i think it was ducey uh
jinsaki slam dunk that [ __ ]
every day of the week
she does he's he's always asking for it
i think i think he's a masochist at this
point when he opens his mouth
at a uh at a press conference the white
house press
in the press room uh jinsaki just
rolls him up and smokes him uh yeah
something he kept going on and on and on
about this obama birthday party
kept going on and on and on and she just
she just
uh turned him into men's meat
she's fantastic isn't she she's i mean i
i i i'm more excited about her than
almost any administration official that
we have
and then main reason why is because we
get clips of
her chopping up that [ __ ] it's
fantastic
absolutely fantastic some of the best
clips on the internet are jin saki
eating steve doocy for lunch it's
fantastic
but they were really concerned they're
really concerned about obama's birthday
party
the outdoor event that has protocols
like you know you have to be vaccinated
you have to test
a negative you know there's certain
protocols to keep everyone
safe that's a goal here you dummies is
keep everyone safe stop
blaming it on immigrants stop it
we know you're racist we've known this
you don't need to prove it to us
we know you're a bunch of racist nazis
you do not have to prove it to us stop
blaming it on immigrants
that's not gonna work because just
blaming on immigrants ain't gonna make
it go away by easter you remember that
it was gonna be gone
poof gone miracle miracle gone
poof here we are delta plus
why did they call it del what what the
[ __ ] can we talk about that for a second
because i've got i
got about six minutes left
why why did we name
why did we name the next wave of variant
to sound like a [ __ ] streaming
service
plus plus is a positive people
it's it's a sign of a positive
i gotta tell you i gotta tell you
this is not a positive thing that is
about to happen
it is not it really we're we're we're
very close to being out of woods on this
if people would go get vaccinated
and they're going to ah this idea that
they're gonna walk through life
and not be able to do this is ridiculous
they're not gonna get a job they're not
gonna be able to go to school
they're not gonna be able to get on an
airplane they're not gonna be able to go
in a concert they're not going to be
able to go anywhere
hell in new york they just decided to do
passports you can't even get a
restaurant a gym
or a theater without being vaccinated
you're not going to be able to go
anywhere so if you go visit new york
what are you gonna do sit in your hotel
room you'll be lucky to even be
let in the hotel lobby without a vaccine
i'm telling you they're going to get
vaccinated whether they like it or not
it's going to happen
i mean there'll be a few outliers that
aren't you know but you'll know they are
because they'll be yelling and screaming
about how they are
you know outside venues outside the
airport
yeah it's my body my choice it's my
right freedom
and [ __ ] that's what they'll be saying
i appreciate you joining me today and i
know there's a lot of stuff that i
missed
i just i've only got an hour and there's
so much
oh so much dumb [ __ ] right now
and i hope i hope we have a little more
next week on
on what actually happened during the
exchange between trump and rosen
i think that's going to be super
important and i think that drip drip
drip that you're gonna see in that slow
walk we'll probably get more news on
friday i would imagine we're gonna have
more drops of news
and that slow drip drip trip is only a
walk towards
um possibly figuring out a way to lock
this guy up
we'll see we'll see how quickly it
happens
but that that's that's what's about to
ensue
and so i'm sorry i'm sorry that we only
do an hour and i missed
so much so much
of the stupidity of the stupid virus
that these spread necks are
spreading around but i do appreciate you
joining us
again if you missed it today don't don't
worry if you missed the whole
you know if you missed parts of it don't
worry it'll be up on youtube
as long as youtube doesn't ban me for
talking about the virus
but if it doesn't if it gets kicked off
you do don't worry about that either
because we're on apple podcast we're on
spotify google podcast you can find us
there you can also find it on twitch
or on twitch i still haven't figured out
what it is but it's over there
it's it goes on that that thing whatever
twitch is it goes on over there
so you can watch it over there too and
you can watch it here on twitter again
you know we'll keep retweeting it to get
it up in the the the the timeline that
way you can keep watching it there
but one other social media platform that
i wanted to tell you about that i had no
idea
uh is clapper clapper a lot of tick tock
little tick tockers have been uh very
frustrated that their videos are getting
banned
so they're moving over to clapper
clapper's kind of like a
tick tock i guess it's very similar so i
opened up a clap account i got the clap
i got the clap everybody and uh i open
up
a clapper account so if you're on
clapper
if you got the clap come and we'll have
the clap
together we can clap and have the clap
together
so go follow me on tick tock uh
subscribe to the youtube channel here
follow me on twitter
and get over to clap if you got a chance
and see what's happened on the clapper
there's a lot of political tick tockers
that are moving over there you'll love
the videos if you like my videos
you'll love their videos you'll love to
see them i appreciate you joining us
join us next week same time same place
wednesday three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern right here
live on twitch on twitter
on youtube and until next week
[ __ ] up you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them